you want to have a good time tonight
[Music]
[Music]
going up
[Music]
is
[Music]
if
[Music]
expensive
[Music]
[Music]
sense of danger
one from
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
up
rain rain rain
hey everyone welcome to moses and
friends i am your host
and backline worker moses storm this is
the show where we take all of our
favorite people
from team coco we put them up live in
your living room
we have a great show today my first
guest
you've seen her on two dope queens she
has a podcast
called couples therapy please welcome
the very funny naomi eck paragon naomi
thank you for being here
thanks for having me moses you're
looking well i've tried for this
you know this is this is the best i've
looked in a week
and i've been prepping for this you look
great thank you for dressing up
well honey i need a reason i need a
reason they're just clothes
sitting in the drawer they're sitting in
the drawers they haven't been touched
have you bought any
anything like any new clothing item yet
i will tell you something i bought three
pairs of shoes
all heels because they were on sale
and i know i have nowhere to go but i
said you cannot
pass by a deal you can't yeah i've
bought i've done two two pairs of shoes
tennis shoes have not
been out yet and now i don't want to
take them out too much time has passed
or i'm like i can't they've been with me
for this whole process
uh yeah this is this is really weird and
i please tell me if i'm wrong about this
but i feel like
for a lot of comedians they really need
an audience but for someone like you at
least the way you perform
i was just re-watching your two-dope
queen set and then
some of your rants you do online it
almost feels like you don't
need an audience to do your thing
you just barrel through like this is my
idea you're either here or not
is that something that uh that you feel
or do you still feel like thinking like
uh
i need it every 15 seconds i i miss an
audience
i miss it so much i do feel like i need
it to
feel as though my rant has done anything
for anyone but myself yeah do you know
what i mean like sometimes it's like
right who is that for you self-indulgent
fool
but if you have laughter it's like wow
i've helped people i've connected
right i think that's always kind of
helped me i think that you know this
idea that
because i think part of why i started
out being a little conversational and
not
too structured i think initially started
out out of being afraid i wouldn't get
the laugh
you know like you know how sometimes in
the comics you know they have that
cadence because they know that laugh is
supposed to come here
and i could never be sure so i sort of
never really gave myself those pauses
or that sense of this is the one spot
you're all supposed to crack up
at oh i know exactly what you're saying
because when you
because as a comedian you're watching
that pause
and you you feel when it doesn't go well
and someone's like and that was the
whole
watermelon so anyway
but you guys that like that just oh the
whole
watermelon you know you say it again
hoping you can kind of set it up
and the extent to which you know
sometimes you might want that laugh to
propel you forward
and if you're not like i'mma propel
myself is there any colloquialisms that
you have
a pet peeve with like mine just for
example is just like
uh what else what do you guys want to
talk about
what do you mean what do you want to
talk about what do you want to talk
about you're the one
with the lights on you you know what
i've never liked
even though like i wouldn't think about
it only because you've asked i realized
yeah i never
like for some reason i'll leave you with
this
there's something like about like i'll
leave you with this because when you get
the light and you know you're about to
wrap
up it's there's i don't know what it is
i don't know what it is about the phrase
i'll leave you with this that feels a
little too
thank you sir well all right master
yeah i think it's a way of it's a way of
letting the hosts know that i know
the light has happened and this is going
to be longer than 30 seconds
right right is what that means i am
going to run the light
so i'll leave you with this so growing
up it wasn't always easy to start my
full one-man show there so you've had
the podcast to really keep you
busy but the complicated thing is you do
it with your husband
well so it is like a work relationship
has that been beneficial for you guys or
have you noticed that like
just couple fights kind of bleed into
what would essentially be a work fight
well here's the thing i think where if
you are living with your partner
in the pandemi you are probably
struggling
with distance wanting some of it okay
getting a break okay
moses i've always said before pandemi i
said the key to a relationship
you gotta miss a [ __ ] okay you gotta
have some time where you ain't seeing
that person's face moses if you want
love to work
yeah and so here we are in the pandemic
it's an apartment honey it's an
apartment he you know
i will sneeze in the living room he'll
say bless you from the office
and i don't like it i don't like it that
is no privacy
no i don't i'm also acquainting with my
partner
and it's a one bedroom i mean it's
shutters it covers the bedroom there's
just nothing
you know i hear like mouth sounds in the
next room
i hear someone's mouth working i know
it's too much and so then when like
so then we go to do the pod and i find
that
the hardest thing is just having
something to talk about you know like i
know some people have started podcasts
in the pandemic and i'm like there's
literally
less to say than ever
yeah you know like i'm like what what's
the new episode what we do we walk to
the couch
i don't have anything to bring to this
podcast moses
well it does feel like even the small
shows i've been doing in backyards it
does feel like everyone's talking about
the same thing
because everyone is home everyone has
the same
stir crazy and then the same news cycle
so
it's really hard to be like i
accidentally bumped into this person on
the bus
there's no personal takes anymore
right i find i've been going to the past
if that makes sense like just like
thinking about stuff
where i'm like oh yeah that childhood
memory might make for a funny story
or that phone call with my aunt could be
something you know i mean stuff that i
would have never
brought up before but i'm like honey i'm
digging i'm digging
kick up family drama for material you
know just like hey remember that
that aunt that faked a heart attack
that really really get into it just to
generate material because it is a point
where
yes it is hard to have a new experience
that is original and then two the
turnaround of material
have you done any any outside lives no i
haven't been out
i haven't been out how's it been it's
been
uh awful everything that would have been
a hell gig last year that you'd be like
absolutely not
um i'd rather eat a gun is now like hey
thank you so much for having me on that
show
would love to come back in two weeks so
every like
outdoor performing for cars performing
for clap machines
the worst case scenario is just a small
taste of what it used to be
so then that makes it the best show
right um the material
more to your question is like the
material needs to turn over even faster
now
right because so much is happening if
you do something about game stop people
like
wow she's dusty
and that was like two hours ago that
happened right right did you buy any
stock
uh no i don't know anything about it
and i also am aware that it's not
interesting to say i don't know anything
about this
that's like the guys are like sports
sports sports like yeah i just
i respect it i don't get it i tried to
learn about it early in choir because
especially because i was like you know
what
if we all about to die i need some
bunker money and i felt like these old
white men they got bunker money and i
said i'm alert
i'ma learn and then your girl bought
some modernist stock and sold it
immediately
before it became ex before it became
money
so i don't know what i'm doing moses
what i'm telling you is i don't know
what i'm doing
after a vaccine no before i bought it
when it was low
maybe when it was low
and no no profit because i didn't
understand that you're supposed to hold
on to these things for a long time
i didn't know until you said that you
didn't know that you should hold on to
it
and i was like well it's not moving no
one seems to be it's not moving so i
guess i'll just give this back
and i thought you almost just like
traded it do you know what i mean like i
pretty much just like was like okay
i gave you this now give me that money
back and it's like that's not what just
happened girl
you just sold stocks i just thought i
was getting my money back
at the height at the height of their
success yeah i thought i was getting a
refund
i've enough to like worry about with
social media and try to post to like
then worry about
my robinhood app i feel like you've kept
on track though because these things
you could easily find distractions that
would take you away from the larger goal
i think you want to be a performer you
want to be a writer or performer and
i think the podcast is allowing you to
do that you're still getting
your voice out there your girls doing
instagram videos i just
need to know that someone's seeing me
yeah accurate incredibly accurate your
trader joe's rat went pretty well online
i connected with that did you connect
with that content do you go to tj's
yeah well we go very rarely we have an
uncompromised person with us
so it is i go in a full gray hazmat suit
a gas mask so i get people like taking
photos of me
liberal cook
but exactly you said you have people
should look it up i mean you have a
whole game plan
to go in there yeah i think it got me as
you you were talking about how people
were smelling
fruit yeah yeah like they're taking off
their masks
is this good is this i mean lemon
like moses it's a pandemi in and out you
ain't ida garten
you ain't in a garden they up in here
trying to get the ripest it's like
honey this is survival also is trader
joe's
you're no culinary expert okay we're all
the tj's because the price is right
so if you could just back up on that
whole thing
because i will tell you the last time i
went because i go to trader joe's now
every six to eight weeks
you know uh me and my betrothed we each
take a cart honey
so you got two carts piled high by the
end
but i went in i have asthma
and um i was allowed to go during senior
hours honey so i was there
it opened at eight i was there at 8 15.
that was beautiful
that was beautiful i'm telling you
it was just us and like 11 old people
but this is what i'll tell you again at
8 15 am
already out of corn flakes come on come
on come on
party out who's buying the corn flakes
these seniors it's the one food they get
are you getting looks from the other
seniors because you look young and
healthy
well as soon as as soon as we walked up
and it was funny because i called in
advance you know because
that's like my one of my uh nightmares
this idea of like
being turned away or being in front of
people and then being like get out of
here loser
like so yeah so i called in advance
and it was literally like some guy named
mikey and i explained he was like he's
like yeah you can come
and i was like are you sure what what do
i say if someone
he goes say i said you could come so
literally i walk up before i even get in
there
the bouncer at the door was like this is
senior hours
and i was like mikey said i could come i
have a house my and i need issues
she was like okay okay go ahead you have
a guy
you have a trader joe's guy now mikey
you gotta say his name what have our
lives become you seem like a club i know
this
guy now you have a trader joe's guy it
helps you get
corn flakes cause it's easy on your
stomach exactly
i wish we had more time to talk we have
a couple more guests but this was
honestly very enjoyable to talk to you
it was so wonderful just to see another
human being
gorgeous the podcast is called couples
therapy i
highly recommend it i was just listening
to it just
in preparation for this and then really
thoroughly enjoyed the show oh i'm so
glad i'm so glad
and then there's rants online so naomi
had paragon
thanks guys that's gonna do it for naomi
thank you so much
for being here my next guest you know
him if you're watching this channel he
needs no introduction please welcome
andy richter
hi moses thank you for having me uh i
met
we were taping so i'm in the courtyard
of
largo um so but you'll hear some traffic
noise i hear a lot of traffic it says
very
i feel like the man on the street the
last time we talked
was that when we were still doing the
show for uh audiences
and you were telling me that on the old
stages you had a place where you could
just go
and disappear have you found a place
there at the largo where you could just
completely disappear
well this courtyard is nice uh
you know it's noisy but it's it's nice
and
uh i i come out here
when conan is doing interviews the zoom
interviews because
uh i just don't want to make no you know
like i'm certainly not going to listen
to the interview
because no it's a speakerphone
conversation yeah he talked to colin
quinn today and like
i heard everything that guy had to say
in 1995
enough with the colin quinn i'm just
kidding do you know there's different
uh races of people in new york and they
came over at different times
no i i love him but but honestly no i
stay out of there just so i don't have
to like worry about
if i get up or you know that the old
seats in the theater will clank or
something
because when we when i first started
here with them
i was in there for one of them and i
just was like ah
i'm too clumsy i should be out here just
so i don't interrupt
um but yeah this is but also too like
this place i've known this place
for a million years you know i mean and
i i've known everybody
here for 20 plus years
so i'm i was always very comfortable in
this place even before we started doing
the conan show here
yeah because we people don't know this
is the hub
of essentially alt comedy where you can
really work on stuff before it becomes a
special people have taped their specials
there
so it is a cool spot and it's cool you
take it so you
the place that you found to disappear to
is the central courtyard
yes yes although you know what i mean
it's a different thing because i'm not
here
i ca if i need to hide in the hour that
i'm here
i got real problems i shouldn't be on
television if i'm that uh
right if i'm there yeah if i need to
hide that much
yeah yeah but this is how you got roped
into this show you were just too central
you were outside you were not smoking
and you're like hey there's this
kid that did stand up once
they asked me and then when i found out
what time it was it was like
i might i just just did it here you know
rather than
normally i would be at home uh you know
in my sad dark little box that i live in
uh but here i you know here it's like i
said i feel like a man on the street
that is something i've noticed i think
people when they do the show for the
first time they're like i hope
conan likes me immediately i was like i
hope
andy doesn't scowl at me because i think
and please tell me if i'm wrong i feel
like you watch stand up like comedians
watch stand up conan is very gracious of
like let's keep the show on the rails
but you i you feel like you know the
mechanics of it of like uh-huh
yeah that happened sure on the conan
show
you know and conan has said this and and
god bless him he never wanted me to be
any different
but mo you know i will sort of laugh as
a
conversational lubricant yeah but most
of the time
i you know i
i laugh when i think something's funny
which i guess is
unusual and i definitely felt when i
went from
new york to la and came out here and had
to go through like the sitcom process of
the table read
and then the rehearsals and everything
where
everyone laughs real hard at everything
over and over and over again yeah yeah
and i just
it's i just feel like you're crying wolf
like you're ultimately going to
not be able to tell the difference
between that's really funny and that's
just okay
and i would have other writers say
things to me
uh say things to me like
you know you're not a big laugher are
you and i would
i would say well yeah actually when
things are funny
you know things are funny yeah looking
at a math equation
and i'm not trying to be a dick i'm not
trying to be a dick but i just think
i'm trying to be honest about that one
part of it and because i always have
felt that the
this kind of job doing a late night talk
show like this
you have to be yourself you have to you
can't
you know you're yourself in a sort of
you know like when company's over
but you're but you got to be yourself if
you're going to be
fake laughing fake reacting it's going
to be
it's going to suck you know and i just
also just don't
i don't want to do that i think that's
what i was nervous about the second time
i did the show
because you guys are more front facing
on stools there
as you can see and you know that you
know all the mechanics you know the
punchline before it's
coming you know that yeah you were not
on a bus
in australia this morning and also to be
to be fair to the stand-ups a lot of
times
you know it's that's the end of our day
pretty much
and i think you know and so it's kind of
like
it's easy to zone out it sounds really
shitty and it probably is kind of shitty
but
i guess i'm shitty no i think it takes
some of the mystery out of it i think it
makes people less nervous to do the show
to know that
yeah everyone's there doing a job just
do your thing table reads
are that you brought up are something
else where it is
way too hot of an audience where it
feels like they got
bullied into laughing yes because it's
like network people there so everyone's
like
that's the joke that i wrote everyone
likes that
have you ever bombed a table read
i have not but i have been involved in
table reads
where someone
gets cocky and thinks oh this is just a
table read so i don't need to
perform at my top abilities here
i can save it or something i don't know
and they get fired
like you can get you can get fired at
any time
and so it's like every time they want to
hear you say a line you better say it
the way like the money way to say it
yes you better have all the coffee or
whatever drugs
make you funny do that because
yeah it is the it's the second to last
audition
yes and i always cringe when actors will
post the deadline article with a
hollywood reporter i'm like booked it
it's like you are so close to getting
you could be gone tomorrow and
everyone's going to be asking me what
happened to that
right right the cw's arrow
that's the same reason that they
recommend that you don't tell people
that you're going to have a baby until
the end of the first trimester
yeah because you might not be having a
baby
it's just because it's just really sad
things obviously losing a human being
and a pilot yeah right up there together
in my mind it's the same there is a
table refresher on you
now because essentially every night
on the kona show you are the only
audience member besides the crew you're
really the only one in the seats what is
that like
i mean does it feel like you're mark
ruffalo's character in shutter island
we're just like helping this man
process like you have a tv show whatever
trauma you need to process
um i mean no it's i'm just
honestly this has just been so from
starting in quarantine
for months and months and months and
then you know and doing the show from
home
and it being completely strange and
you know getting an email and then
shooting a bit myself
getting my own props and being like
doing and i always did it like
immediately when i got the email because
i had nothing else to do
yeah and i'd do the bit and send it off
and then i'd sit there and wait for the
next email where
somebody thought of a bit for me to do
so
coming here was like oh god i get out of
the house
honestly one of the best things about
doing this is that you're around funny
people and that you get to spend
lots of time with funny people and in
fact you know in your personal life
you can spend all so much of your day
with
funny people and you go home and you
used up all your funny and
the people in your house are like hey
where's the funny guy
like oh man i'm tired of being funny
leave me alone
yeah it is hard to talk to people that
are not in commentary the same way
because i think people
comedy say the meanest things to each
other absolutely
like that's like the way the way that we
get to be funny around here
is mostly mean and
i mean and it's it's the kind of meme
that comes from a group of people that
are safe
that feel safe with each other so you
can really
you know you can you can be a jerk and
you can you know and it's
yeah it can be it's so it can be so much
fun and there's such funny stuff
and it's all stuff that could never be
on television just because
it is all cancelable material yes it's
all
either awful awful
you know dark things or it's
about somebody that could sue
i mean it's just yeah it's truly
like one of my favorite things about
doing this for a living it's just to get
around
and they're you know it's people that
are paid to be funny
like they're they're funny yeah which
you know makes the roasting hurt
extra hard yeah yeah they've trained at
this they've been rewarded for
it even from you when you're a baby
comedy baby
you are making fun of each other you are
teasing each other you know
i mean at times it can be a bit much and
it's
it can be more of a young person's game
because you just get older and you're
like
there's enough negativity in the world
you've also
kept up with the podcast you've had
something to do in quarantine that
you're still able to do
yeah yeah i have a podcast it's not been
like focusing
it's been uh it's been nice and it and
it's
definitely in the early days was
sometimes
the only conversation that i would have
with another human being
face to face even if it's virtually face
to face
um i mean i'm always talking to my kids
or texting
with my kids but there were like i say
there were days where
you know that podcast i'd record for two
hours just because i was happy to be
talking to somebody
um and i you know i on the pa i do
just talk to people that i'm interested
in talking to mostly
so there's very little kind of
drudgery kind of interviews it's usually
fun it's somebody that i'm looking
forward to talking to
and i'm glad i had it to do is it
something you're looking forward to
in five years when this is all over
you it's your life in five years oh
uh i'm always the snow yeah i mean the
way this is going this is
brutal this is also freaking crazy
and so unique and so unlike anything
that we've ever been through before that
i don't i can't even picture like i
don't i think about
what am i going to do at the other side
of this and i can't even picture it i
just am like
i don't even i mean it
like there's i've had deep existential
moments of like
who am i and what do i do with
my time and my
you know you know with my emotion
and my actions yeah because other people
the way they react
to you and what you put out it
essentially inadvertently tells you who
you are
at least reinforces the ego or identity
and it's very weird to not have that
like hey what do i do yeah i thought i
would do more i thought this would be
different
yeah i mean uh but i mean it's like down
to like am i gonna
i guess i'll still work in show business
but some days it feels like
am i still gonna work in show business
and you know and quite frankly with the
this show ending in june the tbs show
ended in june and
not really knowing what form
the new show will take is it's
it's weird it's you know it's it's
exciting in many ways to have that kind
of
you know sort of change point and those
kind of moments of change
and i've been through them can be great
and you know they're scary but they can
be really fun and good
um but there's just like i don't have
you know the notion of like planning a
vacation you know like
to make sure that you can get your
reservations like i'm
i'm not even bothering with anything
like that you know i
just because who knows i just
yeah i'm just sitting here waiting for
it to end and then i'll see where my
life goes
that's what i've seen especially with
the comic-con shows like this i didn't
know how active you were
in each of the sketches and segments
like no let's just find it out for this
i think that's a lot of people don't see
that work um conan
relies on me because he
trusts my taste and my judgment so
a lot of the time i just get the is that
good
yeah or no or like i said before it
needs a new ending or it needs this joke
or cut that part you just you need
somebody to turn to and go
tell me i'm not wrong um and if you do
it right
you you get somebody who will tell you
when you're wrong which is
a truly beautiful thing about conan
o'brien is that he's willing
to be wrong he's willing to have to be
differed with
um i mean to a certain extent i can't
say much
he may be here just scream at you after
yeah you could be doing it long enough
and still and still collaborate with
people
absolutely yeah i don't i don't know the
best the room and there
because i'll i'll come up with stuff
that i think is hilarious and then i
find out
you know it's not comedy is not a it's
not a poem
you know it's like it's a democracy
you'll find out that thing you thought
was really hilarious is
not that great and you go oh okay
you know yes hence the need for live
audiences
yeah yeah make the meritocracy work yeah
but this is always
really great you're someone that's uh i
don't know it's very helpful to always
talk to you oh thank you
get your input on things it's a good
perspective thank you for having me
thank you for taking the time to do this
we really appreciate it
no problem and um i'll see you around
campus
yeah be around we know where you are
you're at the courtyard that's right
andy richter everyone
all right thank you moses so much
bye-bye my next guest is a hilarious
stand-up comedian and one of the newest
writers on conan
please welcome skyler higley schuyler
thank you for being here man
thank you for having me what's it like
joining
mid pandemic because if you're in a
writer's room it's essentially a lot of
chemistry and you have to do the
weirdest thing imaginable which is
this cold zoom meeting and technical
errors
it took i would say maybe slightly
longer than
um usual but i think it's fine now like
coming into a
new writing staff i think always the
problem is in a new group of people
it's always like when do i make the joke
and the thing about
zoom is if you try to make a joke at the
same time as somebody else
it's just nobody's gonna hear anything
either of you said
so that was kind of like the first big
hurdle of like
when do i even talk because
everybody is already on the same page
about things
i know you mean other than that like
being in the room
is one of the things i enjoy the most
about my day because
a lot of it on it's particularly with
the conan staff everybody's friends a
lot of it's just like
kind of bullshitting a lot uh the same
thing that andy was talking about
being very mean to each other or not
each other but being mean about things
and making jokes that are like yeah
we're all just like hanging out and then
like a half hour or more into the
meeting
then matt o'brien will be like okay
let's read some pitches
and you know it's like we've been just
doing nothing for
a while yeah but it is a great way to go
in though and
you're talking with a human being and
not just going cold and have to read
incredibly dumb sketch right this is dr
fart helicopter
right and god forbid conan joins the
zoom then we're just like
not even gonna get to any then it's just
like you know conan bits
and then we just are like hanging out
with him and having fun so it's just
like
it the most fun i think someone could
probably have
uh working in the time that we're
working
so you started as a stand-up in chicago
and is this true you grew up mormon
i did um and it was a thing that like
i talk about it in stand-up a lot it was
a thing that i didn't even
think was weird or like something that
people didn't relate to until i was
about a year in
and then everybody's like you grew up
mormon that's like kind of
crazy and i was like oh is it and
they're like yeah nobody's mormon
except for if you grew up in utah where
i grew up then everybody's mormon and
i'm like
yeah it's it's normal for like everybody
in the same state to be
like almost the same religion right and
everybody else is like no
no that is that is a utah thing that is
uh
yeah because it's a very specific one
they get a lot of hate just because it's
so
new yeah another 100 years where
until it's acceptable or maybe just get
out of utah maybe
tour i mean yeah that was that was my
thing because i just had to
like get out because i just i always
felt out of place
in in utah and i didn't like i just
didn't you know
i i wasn't the same as everybody else i
like it's a state that's like what 99.99
white it's like me and the utah jazz are
the only black
people there right and i moved to
chicago and
it like it's it was just much more like
uh i
became myself i think through like
comedy you know i grew up
very religious and there's a back part
of my mind where i'm like
you know what you make a killing is if
you become a church comic
okay um that's something that i had
considered because like
i remember when i was gonna go into
comedy um my mom
uh like told my family and
immediately my grandma got me his dvd
that was like
um like to say like hey if you're gonna
do
comedy you know don't have to like curse
and stuff you could be
like one of these like best mormon
comedians
he had this like specific dvd that i
never watched by the way
that um comedy yeah it was like mormon
comedy that was like
you ever be at church and
you know xyz you take the sacrament and
then you feel connected to
like i don't know how that could be
funny bring them young material but they
make a
killing just imagine being like you're
you're killing it
you're killing it for the lord so you
think god is happy with you the whole
time
yeah and then you get like a giant check
10 of which you give back to the church
but that's okay
like i mean that's got to be a pretty
good living you know what i've convinced
myself i'm gonna go do church comedy now
wow what religion did you grow up uh my
parents
made up their own thing they did they
took a little bit of
yeah catholicism and uh
made up their own thing and um tried to
take that after the roads we were
missionaries with that
and it did not work out we had zero
followers
how long were you a missionary for uh
maybe 10 years
for a long time right yeah but not like
like
help people and like staying with them
and and
and uh you know we're gonna build a
school we were just like uh aggressive
street preachers we'd go
to a concert outside of a utah jazz game
or something and just be screaming at
people
oh my god yeah yeah
there's a lot of pressure in mormonism
like when you turn
uh 18 to like it's like men like
go on missions for like two years where
like that's your whole thing
everybody's seen the book of mormon
musical they know how this works yeah i
was so afraid of like
doing that because like by that time i
was like i'm not gonna
be i can't commit to something like that
for like two years and just do this like
one thing so you guys going like 10
years and then not even being like
knock knock hi how you doing do we want
to talk about this guy but like
screaming at people
that's nuts man yeah it's a lot so
people are you nervous to stand up like
nah as long as i'm not telling
older women they're going to have like
all right that was probably the thing
walmart that gave you the confidence to
be like
yeah if i yeah if i bomb it's like
you know i can bob it's no worse than
the things that i've said to people on
the street yeah but i think uh
missionaries and religious people have
insulated themselves so you can't pop
so if anyone persecutes you they don't
get it they're not saved i think
comedians need that we need a way to
insulate ourselves because now if you
don't do well
or someone hates you it's like they hate
me yeah
well that's what i got that's what i do
is like if i get off stage and i bomb
them like they didn't get it
they don't get any jokes they all you
know i am god
make it about them yeah i think the only
way to
truly navigate um comedy and not like be
uh anxious and depressed all the time is
you're either like anxious and like
self-hating like me or you are
just a huge like narcissist and you
think like everything you do is perfect
and um i mean like i go back and forth
i wish i had more of the second one just
to be like i see the clips that people
release and i see the stuff they put out
and i'm like i wish i had that
confidence
can you imagine the the pathology
involved to like
actually comment something negative
on of like something else that somebody
made
like who are you what do you do if there
are any negative comments on this
i will personally fight each and every
negative comment i will find now you're
inviting them but that's fine because
that's just engagement and it's going to
boost us in the algorithm
that's right negativity rises to the top
it starts the conversation
so people are like oh something there's
nothing interesting about kill that
question good so people want i think we
should start a feud
between us there should be a huge blow
up so we have it in the thumbnail
do you wanna just start just like some
some beef over some sort of like
just some kind of public rivalry yeah
it's gonna be great for our brands
i'm gonna go hard hardcore into
anti-masking
you can be the you'll be the fan
favorite i'll be the villain
and i'll just say i i won't even go
anti-mask they say you wear two masks
now i'm just gonna be
going hard into like i only wear one
mask and that can be our sport
see that's the stance that's the nuance
dance is the one masked guy this guy
sells out pc culture wants him to wear
two masks
well [ __ ] it is gross that's what
that's what generates any sort of heat
success is just the
negativity and i'm 100 down to play the
game
i think we'll we'll get into a fight
about uh joke theft but it's going to be
the worst joke
right i stole from you incredibly corny
yeah he stole my thing about how like
sometimes you take an edible and then
you're suddenly like
so high out of nowhere that was my
comedy market of i took inedible
and then something it's like every time
i hear the stories i'm like you're an
adult
you took an edible plane what did you
think was gonna happen
right it was a story you took an edible
and nothing happened or or the whole
like
i have worked with or around kids and
you know what
i don't like them it's like great like
we
hey like we know hey i love it
okay well we have a very bright future i
like this i can't wait to see you again
perform on a real show
i know uh you feeling it on the show
everyone loves you around there so
hang in there keep keep doing your thing
yeah man thank you so much for having me
of course skylar higley everyone that's
gonna do it for us thank you guys so
much for
watching the show we hope we distracted
you for an hour
uh we'll be back in a couple of weeks we
appreciate you watching
uh thanks to naomi andy and of course
skyler we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
three
she made her face
so much
[Music]
the
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
the kids are all right
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you